on va regarder une petite heure sur
twitch le retour de gary et puis après
on filera on filera sur youtube pour
ceux qui voient en replay est le voit
sur youtube on va faire une petite heure
sur twitch sur la chaîne de tchatche.com
histoire de bas tout simplement de
rester de rester avec avec l'horreur
habituel du jeudi du jeudi soir donc on
est une capture d'écran qu'on va enlever
pour le moment puisqu'on en a pas besoin
et on va on va on va ouvrir le chat en
fait tranquillement voir ce qui se passe
et du coup du coup je regarde juste si
cissé lancé voilà c'est le cas donc
c'est parfait je vais ouvrir le chat à
voir combien de gens combien de gens
passent pas sur twihome motivera vous
abonner à la chaîne twitch de check
point com mais je pense pas qu'on est
grande sur ses jambes plutôt venir après
sur youtube
on verra on verra les cimes vous écrire
les gars y aurait dix minutes avant le
début pour le moment on a parlé on a pas
les parties je vais me balader un petit
peu sur internet du coup en toute
simplicité donc on va faire les trois
premières rondes où les deux premières
je sais pas ça dépend
on va voir comment on faisait bon moyen
de monde qui vient en tout cas à faire
un petit un petit moment et puis après
on filera on filera sur youtube
voir un peu ce qui se passe là-bas que
j'espère que vous passez à un agréable
jeudi un agréable était un agréable mois
d'août si je si je puis dire à fortiori
à voir sur un agréable mois d'août
du coup du coup du coup
actuel numéro deux d amy kitsch est ce
que j'ai publié non j'ai pas du tout vu
sa nouvelle version avec heures avec
komarov j'imagine même ça va être sympa
il faudrait que fort et que je l'essaie
fabrique je l'essaie
mais difficile sur tweets charia tour
toujours moins de monde savait que c'est
plus facile en plus a ajouté la voix de
maurice acheter du coup ça va être sympa
du coup on va voir un peu les gens qui
suivent ce que j'avais dit qu'on ferait
la première heure sur twitch dû voir les
gens qui suivent vraiment continuer sur
youtube ou pas nous on va voir les vrais
de vrais les durs les tatoués
voir ce que ça donne alors on va
commencer dans huit minutes
je vous laisse un peu arrivé je n'aime
pas trop enfin je continue à parler mais
en fait j'aime pas trop parler dans le
vide quand il ya peu de gens du coup on
va se concentrer va se concentrer sur le
début des parties et le début des blitz
donc je naviguais un peu sur internet 1
de mon côté je navigue un peu sur
internet de mon côté
alors
alors alors alors démarre maintenant
dans sept minutes
km 25 personnes alors attendez il faut
que je réussisse à enlever ceci je vais
fabien
vous écrivez à fabien qui à mon avis est
arrivé à new york
alors est ce qu on fait un petit blitz
en attendant on va faire un petit bullet
en attendant histoire de s'occuper un
peu l'esprit ça l'usap chat
avant les cinq minutes qui restent
alors joue contre ivan noob je prête
mettre mes lunettes d'ailleurs ce soir
chansons que je vois pas très bien là
alors on va le mettre en pls allez on va
on va faire un truc qu'on fait jamais on
va ramener le cavalier ici c'est un peu
débile boom voyage avec le fj enquêteurs
est floue et d'autres complètement
improbable complètement stupide
allez on va lui donner la pièce c'est
dans l'esprit alors maintenant on va
donner cette pièce dans l'esprit à fond
il faut qu'on aille mater dans l'esprit
mairesse il fait faux m6 et y'a plus
rien du tout c'est vraiment de la merde
ce que je suis en train de faire c'est
complètement débile
c'est complètement stupide c'est
complètement stupide mais bon c'est des
petits bullet d'attentes complètement
ridicule qui n'ont absolument aucun
intérêt alors on va faire un échec mais
ça sert à rien du coup on est
complètement perdant
ça ne sert à rien de faire un échec on
va quand même le faire ça va passer la
tour devant mais ya pas de mattia rien
c'est vraiment la cata ce bullet mais
bon faut dire on n'était pas très
concentré en train de chanter en même
temps normal je crois qu'ils remettent
avec cavalli ou trois ânes on le voit
pas bon bah si matt pas on va essayer de
survivre
j'ai dû rater un match sur la première
rangée aussi ce qui a peut-être d'amin
dada mahamat il a raté deux matchs
problème c'est qu'il y en a un troisième
qui va arriver ici en e2 et du coup ces
périodes on en refait une petite mais on
voit pas très bien l'écran fait alors ça
c'est une mauvaise voie aulas fait pas
cavalier c6 est discrètement un autre ou
que je voulais jouer ces dames b6 en
fait quand j'avais que j'ai ici sous g7
c'est du grand n'importe quoi mon
adversaire joue très très mal aussi du
coup du coup c'est de la grosse merde
c'est du gros caca c'est blitz ces
bulles est plutôt je vois même pas cet
échec
oulala mais en fait j'ai vraiment
l'impression de mal voir l'écran
après on est plus près avoir garé
qu'autre chose mais c'est de la grosse
merde
du coup lui aussi joue super mal mais
moi encore pire je pense à des cahiers
des trois échecs fera tout absolument
tout est ce que ça peut quand même
suffire tu penses pas mais bon à faire
bessin on va essayer de bloquer le
cavalier ans à 3 que j'essaie de faire
tout repenser un tour g2 et surtout en
france et 8 tours angers 1
ok bon là on va prendre en c1 on va
venir ans et 8
on peut pas vraiment rentrés en fait
à
- 16 heures
faire ce qu'on peut pour pour arnaquer
ça
aof ce matin avec eux quatre n'importe
quoi bon aller dernier avant 2 avant de
voir gary commencer c'est pas glorieux
ne saurait se rattraper à la prochaine
pause
on essaiera se rattraper à la prochaine
je pense que ce qui est à faire mais
peut-être va en tout cas et c'est si
adam prend g7
venir l'adversaire est par exemple non
plus les parties vont commencer allez
allez allez allez faut se dépêcher
devient celui là doit à l'imparfait
nickel juste à temps juste attendre
guerrier qui commence par part car
yakine
mais du coup c'est parti c'est vraiment
pas concentré pas vraiment dû gagner 3 0
c'est un adversaire joli mais la lumière
et allez donc je pousse à la première
partie gary contre cardiaque il faut
revenir au classement faut remonter
faire une remonte à la
faut faire une remontée à dallas garé il
faut tout gagner ce soir enfants et
qu'ils fassent quoi qu'il fasse plus 4
du coup pour revenir à 50% vu que ça
compte double mais je mette mes lunettes
je vois assez mal en fait
beaucoup de commentaires depuis depuis
hier et du coup les visites sont un peu
sale mais du coup depuis a depuis hier
jeu depuis le début de la semaine et du
cou du coup les yeux sont moins en forme
à un grand miroir et ben voilà qui
démarre bien et ben voilà qui démarre
bien ok cavalli c3 donc sur d'un match 4
de mémoire enfin ce qu'elles croient eux
deux
après on chassait cavaliers f3 de
mémoire un scandale sur d'un match
qu'as-tu fait georges et 3 prises
cavalière 3g deux prises et prise vous
avez un peu perdu de matos du coup c'est
pas top top
du coup cavaliers c3 mais je ne connais
absolument pas le grand miroir
donc ok d'un match qu'à 3 e 2 ça ça me
dit vaguement quelque chose même plus
que vaguement et au cadran à ferké f 3
des 4 c'est dans l'esprit c'est dans
l'esprit
du coup
du coureur de kelme arrive en f3 il va
chasser la dame apprend avec le pion en
d4 le foot va prendre un f4 va récupérer
le pion et puis après on recrée à la
main ou laissera le roi au centre
peut-être mais florent f2 le fou en c4 à
tour en est le roi engins on est bien
quand on est heureux et du coup sûr d'un
match 4 2 il est revenu en des huit
quand il s'est dit non je ne vais pas
rester coi pas du tout content mais bon
ça va on va récupérer le cuir f4 et puis
un qe2 et éventuellement il va peut-être
faire g5 pour garder les pions peu dans
la vente contre joue g5 direct mais bon
ok on va faire toujours h41 au pire on
va tout détruire
clic avaler fils est peut-être temps
d'encaisser le plus grand le plus avec 4
pts est il peut être temps d'encaisser
f4
enfin j'imagine en tout cas
j'imagine qu'à prendre un f4 qui joue à
cavalier f3 et puis un puits se
développer et peut-être aussi commencer
par cavalier f3 mais juge qu on voit
qu'on ferait pas froid f4 dam des trois
tests si jamais on a besoin de protéger
le pion tour eu un roi des deux comme ça
ça nous laisse la possibilité si on
prend rapidement f4 devenir rapidement
cacher le roi en fait vers des deux est
de se barrer du coup ce sera un peu
l'idée j'ai pu voir le son dans les
oreilles quand les coups arrive ça qui
avait pas pensé quand je jouais mais
c'est assez désagréable pour jouer en
bullet du coup bon je comprends pas trop
pourquoi ses adversaires jouent pas
ensemble pourquoi gary joue pas je ne
sais pas un problème de de
retransmission ça être un petit peu la
difficulté dans ses murs en fait ne
toujours pas de technologie qui te
permettent de ne retombe pas de débits
correctement sûr que bien sûr que tout
ce qui rime avec et chaque rime avec
complications mais bon ça m'étonnerait
que ces positions j'essaie de faire un
refrain ch
mais là c'est quand même pas possible
que cariat tina réfléchissent au temps
quoique quoique si hockey et irréfléchie
réfléchissent d'autant kefu des quatre
régions il ya un truc avec dam des trois
rois des deux rapidement fait perso ça
permet de protéger le pion le dame sera
pas trop mal placé parce que je sais pas
si on a vraiment le temps de faire trois
f2 bon là non à fortiori parce que je
prends prise et qu'elle prend le café
chaque donc je pense pas qu'on ait le
temps de l'année le roi en f2 mais du
coup dam des trois pour essayer de
ramener la tour en jeu et caché le roi
en c1 pour faire un grand roque à la
main ça me paraît quand même perso assez
logique après après il faut calculer
tout cas les deux joueurs réfléchissent
je vois pas trop comment on peut faire
d'autre en fait ce que si on tente e5
direct j'ai peur qu'il faut france et
trois de cinq français 3 puis on prend
un f6 d'emprunt f6 et on réattaque le
fouet f4 du coup à minima au kefu g5 un
autre moyen de protéger le point 4 via
le clouage mais j'aime moins je sais pas
s'ils avaient un problème concret après
après dam des trois occasions qui fait b
prend il double les pions mais juste
suis pas vraiment eu avec son roi
ok des six du coup sur re5 l'idée c'est
probablement de faire prise prisé de
prendre ici ou de joie et cash six
cavaliers 3 logique donc vraiment jouer
avec royal de fous des trois mêlées peut
pas faire bref deux pour le moment parce
que même si le cavalier cloud et vous
voyez on peut faire cavalier prou quatre
échecs et regagner le food incroyable de
n'est pas possible pour le moment donc
il a fait fou prend f6 dame prend f60 f2
ok je suis pas méga fan mais bon d'un
autre côté les blancs ont toujours une
bonne position il veut juste faire
[ __ ] ou des trois mètres la tour par
exemple ont eu un jouet roi g1 est en
fait il va rester avec un gros centre
bon c'est tout à fait jouable pour les
blancs ça a même l'air pas mal en fait
c'est simple et noir viennent essai de
contre attaquer le centre là encore
logique et j'imagine foot est roi
donc il faut quand même finir le
développement et faire jouer cette tour
fou des trois preuves faire gaffe avec
cavalli sait si c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
des problèmes avec ce pion du coup h3
encore un proof et l'équipe pourrait
éviter fou g4 pas bête
c'est quand même beaucoup trop coup
prophylactique pour le moment mais bon
du coup on va voir
tours 8 bon il faut bien protéger
j'imagine qu'il veut ramener leur le
front des trois pour que cavalier celles
ci soient plus forts et mena vraiment le
pion des quatre en fait une fois que le
fousseret en d3 quand on va faire car
lycées 6 le pion décade du coût sera
plus protégé par la dame
du coup il fait dan détroit ça manque un
peu de ça manque un peu de liant le jeu
de gary après ça va mais peut-être même
un coup comme b6 peut être pénible vous
savez j'aurais avec l'idée de faire x 6
ou éventuellement même fougue et 7 pour
venir dans le dans le cyan qu'eto'o
parce que si on joue des cinq après il y
aura qu'à aider cette cavale ie5 la case
de 5 sera faible mais un truc comme b6
ça peut être assez vicieux comme coup
d'ailleurs il le joue d'ailleurs il le
jour ok tout revient bien des le pian
fou 17 du coup ils mènent confiant
qu'eto'o est peut-être à un certain
moment donné il aura du fou à 6 du coup
pour le mans fuhe de interdit parce
qu'elle pût 1 4 qui reste en prise est
toujours dé 5,1 problématique à cause
sky qui arrive en 5e fou très bien placé
et du confluent jaliens se replacent
monde de fous parce que du coup une
pions h3 mon sermon groupe
prophylactique à l'époque mais moins
utiles qui est peut-être g4 dans
l'esprit proposé par fabien chez gaspard
est toujours intéressant c'est dans
l'esprit ça permettrait développer le
fou en g2 après pourquoi pas tout bref
un roi g1 et ça joue quand même moi j'ai
trois soyons fous net faisant labadie
mines moyens de se développer ici le
pion dkt emprise et +14 fin peut pas on
peux pas trop bouger nos pièces si on
fait des cinq on l'a dit on par les 15,5
c'est chiant mais j'ai trois c'est un
peu mou du caleçon sahara j'ai cassé
plus d'enfants dans l'esprit des cas et
c6 logis qui développe qui est chance ou
g2 assez rapidement j'imagine j'imagine
bon ok et puis après tout reste un
rouage et un bon sajoo 1 et donc à 3 g
pas forcément compris la profondeur du
truc
ah parce qu'ils avaient peur excusez-moi
adoption prend puis on prend un cavalier
b4 donc à trois c'est fait pour éviter
ça
look et tour fr cyrus a fait retour f1
revient ça peut aller tour f1 revient
c'est plutôt bien mais ça va on joue
pour effet un moyen et flex plaît let's
catch s
quel genre mais le serment de ne pas
faire un truc genre eu 5 des 5 c 4 kw à
bout dégage donc et tour trois tours est
ok avec l'idée peut-être de faire re 5
après ok pourquoi pas remettre la tour
en 3 j'aime bien c'est pas mal aussi
il m'a l'air pas mal garé là il a réussi
à déstabiliser sergei la tour en e1 le
roi en géant et en avant guingamp mais
qui revient tout re quand même aller
tour f1 du coup là j'ai pas trop compris
là il se passe un truc je ne sais pas
ces papous et la place et tours 3 entre
temps il devait y avoir une raison non
mais c'est tout bon
menaces ou prend 1,4 tourer maintenant
mais mon l'autre va mettre le cavalier
en effet 6 du coût et du coup va taper
sur quatre
donc il rage et un cavalier f6 sur vous
prend 1,4 et les trucs genre dames 2 et
le four est cloué ou peut-être même to
run away surtout prendre 4 était un truc
marrant genre tour eu un fou prend des
trois tours cette prise prise et il ya
ça et ça qui reste en prise à la fin
encore qui a peut-être fou et 5 g 4 je
sais pas ça continue peut-être mais ok
mon nom il a fait dames 2 surtout prend
1,4 et l'autre fait des 5
et du coup c'est un peu la question que
je me pose et si l'autre variante
marchés passés qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant en fait parce que le clouage
c'est bien beau mais pour le moment la
pièce ans le 4 est protégé par un pion
et on peut pas l'attaquer avec un autre
pion qu'au maximum on va simplement
récupérer le pur 4 au kg 6 il protège un
peu mon peut récupérer en quatre mais
j'ai l'impression que l'écho la
conséquence de tous ces échanges là bas
on peut pas encore récupéré en plus du
conte reste avec un pion de moins mais
ok on est mieux au temps mais on a quand
même une poubelle
ok on crée un pôle illusion avec des
ménages pas kf5 match en m6 où là on est
on est parti là peut-être un peu plus
que l'illusion peut-être qu'il s'est un
peu trompé car ea qui n'est peut-être
sur dame g5 il est vraiment obligé de
faire qu'avait à chaque et répéter les
coups ok partie offensive et en bulgarie
dans son esprit ok gaye g7
il évite le père pète et il menace f5
c'est chiant qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
avec gary aller gary troupe jouer un
coup fait quelque chose s'il te plaît
dans me2 non il va se rendre à saint
caprais et l'autre va pousser tous ses
pions à ces horribles
c'est horrible série a réussi à
installer le pion f5
maintenant c'est un pion de plus pour
pour sergei et une position
complètement dominante le cavalier va
arriver alors j'ai cinq f3 voilà
exactement
on va être obligé de la chine calloc'h
allez faut lâcher la cloche chez faut y
aller les gars y aller on a lâché la
kalach mons activée c'est pas mal la
tour défend le pion c3 et à sa qui est
défendue aller à l'esbroufé larnack on
comprend et autant ne sais pas combien
de temps mal on y va quoi boum
on en a vu d'autres peut-être un père
peut-être quelque chose
ça c'est pas très harmonieuse accueille
en h4 machin mais quand même il ya des
trucs qui peuvent arriver c'est du blitz
sait pas trop comment l'art et autour a
eu en c3 on est en train de souffrir
grave le pion est fait clouer tout est
cloué c'est de la merde d'être damas
deux échecs à un échec mais bon il va de
toute façon séparée attention elle a
joué un coup il s'est passé des trucs
sais pas c'est quoi ce passé qui avait
projet si ce boom à fond dans l'esprit
mais le problème c'est qu'on se prend d
échec à aimer une sérieuse ne peut pas
reprendre ses regagne va reprendre en g6
qui interpète est ce que gary va sauver
un père pète c'est possible c'est
possible c'est possible il ya des échecs
de partout il ne peut pas remonter au
temps on s'y fait plus on prendra me
prends à perpète
c'est possible que gary vous ai fait un
tour de magie la dame de sergei revient
oui il peut essayer de faire plusieurs
échecs pour essayer de ramener sa dame
sur une bonne case mais ce quelle case
et cette bonne case
telle est la question reste yeux ramener
sa dame est ce qu'il ya vraiment quelque
part
eh bien je gary roigé 1 pour éviter des
dames e cat échec l'impression que c'est
bon ouais ça fait nul
allez on sait pas trop comment s'est
passée segnora échec
c'était un peu n'importe quoi mais sa
tenue je sais pas vraiment comment
voilà on était quand même très très mal
mais au québec à l'étranger 6 ressources
fuld et peut-être tour c'est d'ailleurs
là notre sauce moussa là j'ai
l'impression que c'était notre sauce
mousseuse games à leur tour ces deux
c'était un peu une dame de moins pour
gary armand que je me trompe pas si
quelqu'un voit quelque chose dans le
chat après tour ces deux sa part été sa
part et c'est ok t'es tu voulais faire
cavalier f4 3,8 et cavaliers eux deux
mais ça paraît notre sauce nous paraît
un peu de la merde mais bon ça va il
s'en est bien il s'en est bien tiré dans
les styles d'autres résultats
il ya des nuls 2000 gaz a vaincu navarra
idée nul 2 partout allez on va voir
caruana contre fabiano
alors que se passe-t-il ici qu'est ce
que c'est que cette merde mais ils
pompent partout et ponts qui pousse
moqué la tour en f1 qui défend tous les
pions et fabiano
fidèle à sa réputation pas super bon au
blitz janvier 2008 et tout mais j'ai
passé vlad qui toujours sac n'est pas
super bon beat tuque ont fait confiance
à vannes du coup le qui a perdu
domingues dont non le cac gagne et qui a
battu caruana dominguez qui a battu
navarra et que des nuls vallourec perd
2,3 bullet en attendant allez on se dit
bullet en attendant là on joue contre un
mec plein cytos bon ben ok à la rigueur
on donne envie de prendre là je sais pas
c'est dans l'esprit enfin j'avais envie
de faire pousser 4 mince j'ai
l'impression que ça marche parce que je
voulais faire et que là je fais
n'importe quoi mais ok c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave quand va faire fous ces
quatre je fais n'importe quoi
n'arrive pas à faire de bullet entre
entre les commentaires de partie très
difficile
on va essayer de laisser de faire ce
qu'on peut
ok ouais c'est ce père qui a aidé ici ce
qui est france et 4 malheureusement il
l'a vu on n'a plus trop de temps
comment se bat bien mais là ça être un
peu de la merde maintenant comment
pêcher en empêcher tous à chasser va
venir se battre à fond
les cavaliers prend malheureusement ok
il ne le voit pas quelle mission c'est
bien de la merde quand même
ok on a essayé de pousser les pions
comme on peut hein
et comme dirait mur tu as pousse un pion
quoi
ah dommage dommage dommage ouvrage
dommage dommage dommage dommage on était
pas loin n'était pas loin c'était bien
revenu de lui prendre ça on va gravir
vous avez une petite pause qu'est ce que
fait ce mec c'est qui ce type c'est qui
ces types ses amis ça c'est des amis ça
ils se foutent de votre gueule quand ils
te donnent une dame en un coup alors
qu'on en fait mine après c'est gary
pressé le retour de gary on va faire une
espèce de caisse qui joue [ __ ]
qu'est-ce qui fait c'est absolument
n'importe quoi c'est des échecs ça je
comprends est ce qui se passe je ramène
mon cavalier quelque part je vais jouer
à les bouger ce cas badges et les
ramener au g4 en fait je vais aller par
là bas en fait je passe c'est ce que
j'ai fait c'était bien mais bon j'espère
angers 4 pour alain fc issy pranger
reprendre 2 je veux voir la colonne f
ok s'il prend pas ou qu'on va faire food
et un ça va couvrir ça on va essayer bon
ok c'est pas grave si vous cette colonne
je m'en fiche
ça me permet d'ouvrir madame est normal
est mon cavagnan f6 ça ça va être bien
ça pour encaisser ça
il faut qu'on se dépêche pas les parties
sont en train de reprendre
apprendre ici du coup à l'aller des
pages sur les parties reprennent
je ne sais pas si les parties ont repris
ou pas je pensais toutes les 20 minutes
mais je ne suis pas sûr il faut qu'on se
dépêche faut qu'on se dépêche faut qu'on
se dépêche tracé champ
mais pas abandonné mais bon ça va on va
le mat et on va le maté ya ma tante 3
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
allez hop on est reparti sur gary comme
ça c'est fait non alors ok du coup c'est
toutes les demi heures c'est toutes les
combines est ce que quelqu'un sait qu'en
reprend reprend à 20h30 au qui reprend
20h30 ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir
aller les taquineries ambühl est encore
encore 5 6 minutes sûr qu'on va faire
les deux les deux premières les deux
frères participe là pourquoi la la la
prochaine on va aller à faire les deux
frères ont dit si puisqu'on va aller sur
youtube
histoire de voir qui suit qui suit
combien convient collet de personnes
sont venues sur tweets du coup bon allez
on s'en fout si jamais on donne la dame
en d5 je sais pas on s'en fiche
complètement
je pense que donner la dame sait c'est
dans l'esprit comme dirait mur tu as
donné une dame qui l'a pas pas les opca
id4 on est de partout c'est un peu
pénible quand on va prendre ça en fin
pénible si j'aurais voulu qu'ils
protègent pas sa tour avec son machin
qui est enfin les sources de rayons x de
partout manquer
n'a pas du tout envie d'échanger ça
tient à faire qui prend ces deux dames
français 4 voilà ça c'est dans l'esprit
je suis pas sûr que ça marche parce
qu'il ya f5 après ou cavaliers ici mais
qui sait peut-être dame échec
intermédiaires et cavaliers 3 et comme
ça on va lui prendre
ça l'a en fait et on va à une menace à
qui on va venir ici c'est un peu de la
tactique de partout mais ça on navigue
en naviguant des lacs navigateur il te
dire j'ai envie de te dire hashtag
kersauson quoi ouais ils menacent
m'attendais très taquin
ça va plus ça va plus ça va plus on aime
bien on aime bien les gens comme ça ici
et du coup on va et échanger les dames
ça ça te calmer ok ok ok ok ok ok ok on
est on est on est sous contrôle
normalement il met en échec deux échecs
trois échecs mais à lecavalier qui
revient bout le cavalier qui revient en
17 et u dégage tu dégages avec adama
diop
allez c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
c'est fini reviens king gold le roi
alors fait très attention su prévenir le
roi
et ouais tu vas on fait un peu de la
merde la nuque et du coup j'ai pris 10
et donner le pion je sentais que ça se
passait mal
et puis bon on est à fond dans l'esprit
honnêtement voilà boom foot est roi
boum j'ai quatre mains ça j'avais pas vu
évidemment mais qui en a fait boum 2
fois rapport à mai de la tour ici dans
l'avenir prendre là va ramener une
deuxième tour voilà on à fond dans
l'esprit les gens là on est à fond dans
l'esprit alors attaqué ça mais ça je
suis pas sûr que ce soit pas de la
grosse daube justement à cause de ce
coup et du fait qu'on va prendre là mais
ça sent un peu le cac a aussi fait 5
adam prend g7 je suis très heureux le
problème c'est que s'il fait ça je ne
trouve pas vraiment de menaces avec le
cavalier ici mais c'est un peu débile
je ne trouve pas de nouvelles menaces
c'est un peu débile
crédit nasa c'est important aux échecs
ou sans bulles est ok ok ok on a perdu
on a tenté le beau jeu qu'on va revoir
en faire une petite
ok va prendre on va apprendre et on va
faire ça du coup on est bien
ça va tout échanger leur revenir
hop un peu navigué avec lecavalier
ça change de structure de pioncer cool
il va le prendre ce cavalier je le sens
non il y aura ramené la dame en h4 boum
boum boum ça s'est pas mal passée la rai
3 4 derniers coups sont assez sympa pour
nous boom va faire un petit boom ici on
va revenir 4 en fait on va pas se
fatiguer et monkey on va faire f 5 x 6
on va taper le pur 3 en fait tout
bêtement on va jouer facile on va la
jouer facile tranquille
en fait quand même un peu de la daube
quand même fait de la super merde mais
bon ça devrait passer mais bon c'est
complètement stupide 1 j'ai fait une
garicoix j'ai fait une galerie
en sont rois maintenant quand même assez
mal placé on va pousser le pion mais bon
on est mal autant quoi c'est minimale
pour rien
ok ça c'est cool
ok on a juste assez de temps pour faire
une dernière on finit vers les parties
du coup vous me direz après dans le chat
je vais pas regarder pour le moment
j'essaye d'être concentré on va prendre
prendre prendre et faire un choix
il ya une chose que vous pensez de ces
petits c petite interview de bullet est
ce que ça vous plaît est ce que c'est de
la merde c'est de la mer c'est
complètement de la merde ce truc pas
fous ces deux tu donnes un pull en un
coup heureusement qu'ils le voient pas
heureusement qu'ils le voient pas c'est
le beau jeu de pas voir les plans d'un
gta iii on va préparer dam des trois ans
on n'est pas des fins on n'est pas des
ondes ou pas dans la finesse je vois
rien je ne vois rien on ne joue pas dans
la finesse
inquiets mais tu peux prendre prendre
prendre prendre ça et si tu prends ici
je suis très heureux en fait les cases
noires là je passe sur site et une bonne
idée de d'otan donné les cases noires
tonton
pour le manceau travailleurs se bat bien
mais quand même c'est un peu au nom
comment je vois pas la tour en un coup
quelle catastrophe comme apprendre ça
ça craint quand même ne pas avoir vu
cette tour en un coup ok on est encore
dans la partie où la tour en un coup tu
dégages vous l'échec tu dégage tu
dégages suis dégage avec ton cavaliers
et tu dégages
ok après on a passé des pions adam ça ce
sera une autre leçon qu'il faudrait
réussir à apprendre mais normalement ce
qui concerne gagner cette finale en
savent à quoi un ça je suis pas mal pour
gagner ça on va pas faire patte
ok et du coup on est pile poil à temps
pour la partie de gary si ça c'est pas
le beau jeu
si ça c'est pas le beau jeu d'être pile
pour elle attend pour la partie de gary
alors faut encore la trouver
elle est là
et voilà ça a commencé
la femme dit violent mais non je vis
d'eux des n'annonce à nous polluent la
chaîne pas de vidéo la longue si raide m
alors du coup une petite sicilienne du
cougar et avec les normes on est pièces
blanches qu'on suit l inverse et cette
voix nepomniachi a pas bon c'est pas lui
qui avait fait tomber 5 échecs le soit
guerrier à la police à la nage en patins
et décident de faire flouer 2 comme
maxime
du coup qui réussissent à rentrer dans
une chef dingue garric et chaud patate
dans les galeries bouge pas emboîté
pions b5 fou mais cette île et b17
gariel et noir
ça se développe au quai les plans
classique une structure irisson hérisson
ils sont chauds quoi du coup il ramenait
la tour en d1 j'imagine ensuite
peut-être faire f4 fouet f3 des trucs un
peu d'allemand l'esprit quoi prendre de
l'espace gare hier pas trop l'espace
mais c'est un peu comme analyse un
élastique un moment donné il va faire f
des 5 ou des 5 et puis tout va s'ouvrir
et puis les pièces blanches sont hyper
mal placé du coup ici
du coup il sait après d'amd 2 comment
est-ce qu'on contient et gary ça doit
pas être un poids habituel puisque nos
10e coup d'une variante qui est quand
même assez théorique habituellement du
coup voir gary réfléchir avec tous
rêvent d un ok pourquoi pas soit il faut
après ils font un truc avec 4,4 fois f3
j'ai même une partie une fois ou hikaru
avait fait roi h un g4 g5 à fond dans
l'esprit mais c'est rarissime mais bon
c'est pas dans l'esprit au food et sat
qui va faire tour des huit tours c8
peut-être le flou à 8o km 3 pour moi il
joue modestement tu aurais vu des huit
tours à ses 8 août au rabé huit tours à
ses huit faut 8
d'après le pouce et préparait des cinq
quitte à petit
la vision jockey et b3 et kruska i d 4
pouces et 6 seraient pas mal leurs
cadets 4 6 et 6,5 aussi pas mal pour
aller viser la casse ces quatre
peut-être tour c'est 8 après du coup il
veut profiter du fait qu'ils avaient
trois n'est pas été joué
du coup le kave arrivants ces quatre
quidams e1 du coup ils anticipent
cavaliers ses quatre passes prendre une
fourchette entre le fouet la dame ce que
keynes et 4 il attaquerait ces deux
pièces et coutour c8 logique un sommet
sur la colonne semi ouverte jusque là
c'est pas sorcier pas sorcier
toujours calé ses quatre jeux parce que
faire du christ et quatre en fait mais
bon je joue pas trop ses positions du
coup pas facile mais parce que tu
attaques le foot attaque l'option quand
même mettre le français en tête mais bon
c'est un peu moche qu'il faut afin
hercule le fou logix permet de réactiver
la dame sur la colonne le foie s'est
bien passé en f1 en avait parlé dans la
vidéo avec maximin les fous qui aime
bien revenir sur la case de départ
du coup est peut-être le four à revenir
en c1 mais bon je sais pas on va voir du
coup c'est la question que je me posais
du coup je suis content qu'elle sait
qu'à pareille sur l'échiquier
ok donc ils ont échangé france cas de
l'âme français 4 lequel parce qu'ils
sont mauvais fou mais c'est quand même
la paire de foot je ne sais pas mais je
comprends pas du tout comment les blancs
peuvent être mieux ici
et du coup cette balance un truc à la d5
fou b4 à un moment donné tout ouvrir
avec la perte de fou ça me paraît quand
même pas top pour yann
donc à 5 spirit est peut-être un moment
donné db5 ça peut paraître de gagner la
case b si ce qui est bon pourquoi pas ça
bloque un peu la structure de pions
noirs
why not mais la gare il peut peut-être
faire dans la violence quoi des cinq
bouts mais sur des saints qui a
peut-être 5 et le cavalier peut se
retrouver un peu à geof squared
croissance en cases du coût des cinq
marche pas encore peut-être cinq dessins
calais boom tu lui envoies tout quoi tu
donnes un pion fou donc elle a fait un
bébé 4 menacé le pion b2 cavaliers b3g
tellement vrai que la position souvlaki
le défonce qui se venge de sa dette de
la défaite ce qu'on se rappelle que sa
défaite contre eux contre yann qui avait
lancé la mauvaise forme qu'elle alger
3eme la soupe prend 1,6 ça c'est pas
c'est pas grand chose à voir sentir et
numériques sous y fait des tours prend
ces trois aussi un moment donné vous
sacrifier la qualité on s'en fout tu
dégages de partout malte à 3h witch et
pas juste simplement je vois pas
vraiment d'autres menaces ou quelques
habillages 5e va probablement venir
angers 4 avec saddam peut-être s'il
vient à angers 4 un moment donné il y
aura un truc comme f5 qui va arriver
peut-être juste faire cavalier apsys
revenir et répéter les coups pourquoi
pas fabien qui nous proposent leur tour
des 8 x 8 et des cinq ans elle pour tout
envoyer qui est un mais deux
cavalia ici s'il revient il fasse
vraiment contrefaire une nulle gars rien
contre contre yann pourquoi pas
fou mais ici ce du coup faut faire gaffe
ils menacent peut-être n'ont pas encore
tous jaca puisqu'à le fou qui protège
mais à un moment si gary fait fou aussi
sur à tour à 4 et la lame sera enfermée
faut faire gaffe à sa mère surtout que
ce diable de yann il peur à penser à ça
a eu cinq j'aime bien dans l'idée que
pour le moment on peut pas venir du tout
utilisé cette caste des 5 avec les
blancs peut pas venir en profiter et du
coup ils préparent peut-être fou et six
dessins qu'il va falloir faire attention
à la dame
il va falloir faire très attention à
cette dame en b 4 là pour pour gary
vraiment je pense qu'il l'a vu mais ça
me fait toujours un peu peur
ok dam des deux noms mais le mec tente
le piège j'en suis sûr je suis sûre à
200% qu'il a qu'une envie c'est que gary
voit pas que la dame peut être enfermé
au kheddam c4 ça va et ça fait peur
l'espace d'un instant c'est un piège qui
pouvait être assez bas c'est malin
nicu fèves 2-2 parfois à faire pousser
si ces dessins quand même un moment
donné un faux réussir à le jouer comme
ceux des cinq peut-être des cinq
maintenant que l'on prend est fou b4
quoi dans l'esprit à la galerie balance
des pions dans ta gueule et on attaque
donc il faut aussi se maintenant donc
c'est à dire que quand il a fait dame c4
il a vu les problèmes de d'enfermement
de dames qui doit pas avoir peur de
cavaliers à quatre cavaliers bay 6 ha
oui pour le mans qui a quatre pas
possible aussi puisqu'elle pioncer de
l'emprise donc pas mal pas mal pas mal
ok fou h4 je vous ai surtout à l'heure
où je vais peut-être g5
on chasse quand on s'en fout tour des
milk est vraiment fou prend 1,6 en
revanche on est ok juste ont fait g5 on
le chassera tu pars
du coup tour des huit
donc ta main et là j'ai quand même envie
de te faire g5 et de dégager des pièces
de merde des cas d'écart avec tes pièces
de partout après des cinq ans lui pousse
tous dessus on défonce et dames c6 on
prépare on prépare et puis après tout
d'un coup boom tu dégages
je vais peut-être faire fou prend b3
aussi je la sens bien cette partie
je la sens bien donc elle a une face
j'ai pas trop compris pourquoi ramener
la dame en 8 je peux pas vous expliquer
juste aucune idée pourquoi est ce qu'on
n'a pas pourquoi est ce qu on dribble
autant qu'ils veulent et ce qu'il veut
faire un truc genre dingue georges et 5
d'alger cette dame et fils d'alger cette
norme qui n'y croient pas ça c'est mes
délires mais justement pas trop pourquoi
avoir ramené la dame n'était pas apte en
danger qui se barre avec son fouet f2
j'ai peut-être revenir vers b 6 vous
êtes remettre les pièces dans le bon
ordre en fait il m'a l'air d'un peu trop
tricoté gary ça tricote un peu
ça tricote un peu trop la cote et gary
mais allez on y croit ces pages vous
c'est vraiment dommage d'avoir d'être
allé cacher cette dame qui était pas si
mal placé léman gary devait avoir ses
raisons à l'égard y aller petit
allez gamin je dois aller pâtit cavalia
un non mais attends c'est pas sérieux
des coups comme ça ok je pense qu'il
voulait pas bouger une pioncer ce qui
est pris avec le cavalier tout ça mais
quand obligé de jouer cavalier a quand
même ça fait un peu pleuré quoi la fin
enfin je sais pas comment tu peux avoir
envie de jouer secousse a envie de
chialer quand tu joues ça c'est fou des
huit on met une petite pression et
éventuellement sur le pion à cinq
contrôles un peu la casse d ici c'est
bien joué c'est bien je vais garer
quelqu'un me fahmi un b3 c4 qui a laissé
deux cahiers b4 mais bon c'est un b 4
mai un éventuellement de pions bessette
peuvent apprendre ces deux il faut
peut-être y aller la galerie 1 et bouger
5 kg il prend des saints qui arrête la
tour ans et sept du coup changement de
structure de pions eu d'effort c'est
donc là on a complètement changé surtout
deux pions mais surtour c7 faut faire
gaffe à tour b6 quand même manqué tour
reffouh b6 pardon pour ces quatre et sur
dame prend bessette qu'est-ce qui l'a
garé là fou prend à 5 mais il ya dame
prend à 6,6 perrin puis on l'a garé et
al pions des six après derrière
attention gare y aller eux quatre ces
biens allez on y va on y va en force
on voulait activités boom vous prend à 5
c 3 il a protégé la tour des dames b5 on
échange les dames et maintenant vas te
parler de ton cavaliers mais bon le
cavalier peut revenir en un seul coup en
b3 et venir tour est attaqué il va
réattaquer le fou il va regagner un
tempo il sera pas si mal placé mais il
est fort ce yann en blitz
il est dangereux pas de super casse pour
notre fou cavaliers d2 il regagne un
tempo sur la tour s et ce car il ya un
qui nous fait la misère tour à 4 il va
encaisser un pion au 4 mai on a senti
s'est passé un truc qui n'allait pas
pour gary difficile à dire quoi
difficile à dire quand mais il ya un
truc qui n'allait pas dans cette partie
quelquun peut-être tour à 200 m x lion
peu l'arnaqué ont peu l'arnaqué
peut-être faire b4 à un moment donné
c'est d'aller taper les plus belles
dames et sauver la nuit là les gars il
faut sauver la nulle aller le demi point
gary ce serait trop pénible de te voir
re perdre contre eux gagnent bien trop
pénible heureusement que maxime labatut
sinon la pénibilité serait trop forte
c'est pas le mec le plus intelligent
quand même du circuit il faut le battre
ba ba du coup faire nul et reviendront
ici c'est qd on fout fawcett y tu peux
pas faire tour prostate vas-y touche
tout le foot ou reprendre cède 3 mc du
couloir fait défende son pion messi fait
autour d'eux le truc c'est qu'on va
faire fou prend ces trois faut que je le
montre si les tours de y avait foule
france et 3 puis en france et trois
tours points à 2 tours prend 1 er tour
des un es tu dégages avec un mât du coup
leur bon c'est cool c'est cool c'est
cool ils ont fait nul ils ont répété les
coûts yann n'a pas pu gagner c'est cool
ou pas ça lui fera les pieds quoi tu
dégages
alors voir le teaser du tournoi
en tout cas qui était leader du tournoi
les vols qui les voit je pense qu'après
food est un fou j'ai 4 ans auront cette
finale nuls théorique mais elle n'est
pas si facile à tenir peut-être sans le
pion à val serait nul d'ailleurs ok donc
il va réussir à récupérer le pion à et
du coup faut réussir à garder le roi
vers eux pour pas se faire mater dans le
coin et pour être capable en cas de
sacrifice de qualité de revenir vers g8
donc il faut garder le roi un peu denses
dans dans le centre mais pas aller trop
loin non plus là nous l'a expliqué hier
malgré déjà un peu regardé ça me paraît
jamais aussi simple affaire me l'a dit
que ça peut être très compliqué enfin
avec la tout est simple après avec vlad
tout est simple
qui aura des trophées faire gaffe comme
j'aime pas trop le fait enfin en fait je
suis plutôt pour les vannes mais faut
qu'il fasse gaffe david ce que son roi
se fait un peu déporté vers la dame et
du coup il faudra qu'ils soient capables
de revenir à temps mais bon pour le
moment ça va
mais bon difficile d'annuler ces trucs
là on va voir on va voir on va voir mais
je pense qu'en blitz avec en cadence
bronstein et quelques secondes sur la
pendule je pense que c'est infernal à
tenir en fait qui est du coup du coup il
est sur la huitième maintenant mais il
tient bien
qui fait barrière au qui repart avec le
roi de l'autre côté 1 et ça va il la
tient bien
appréciant 8 vraiment pas de progrès de
la part de l'even bienvenue de navarra
qui tient bien
mais c'est sûr qu'il connaît
c'est sûr qu'il connaît
sûr que c'est pas la meilleure cadence
du monde la brunch taille mais bon
comment ne pas être tenté de ne pas
apprendre la seule mauvaise idée du
joueur c'était quand même très tentant
ne sais pas ils se sont quand même bien
battu au niveau d'aidé partage aussi
pour le tournoi le truc que s'il ya deux
mecs qui sont départagera les mecs
jouent entre eux mais s'il ya trois mecs
on départage or là non le premier gagne
vraiment à là c'est différent il
travaillait en départage ça change tout
citer 2 tu fait citer 3 ou 4 août ou en
fait on s'en fout il ya plus de
départage c'est fini du coup vous c'est
vrai qu'il réussisse à faire affaire
très très très fort à ce niveau là le
grande chez ce tour du côté règlement
idiot break alors la médaille médaille
d'or
mais quand même en train de la tenir
je vous le fou contre la case aussi
c'est le roi revient toujours et c'est
le coin c'est du côté mais à mon avis
impossible
il la connaît il a connu il la tient
avec laurent g8 c'est peut-être gagnant
est ce que disait vlad mais bon là j'ai
l'impression que ça tient quand même à
moins ce qu'un des joueurs tombent c'est
possible de tomber
d'ailleurs non ok ils ont fait mieux ils
ont fait nul ils ont fait nul donc du
coup du coup nous on va on va filer vers
youtube pour pour la suite du coup on
avait fait ce petit passage ce petit
passage sur switch pas combien de gens
ont suivi du coup c'est intéressant a le
temps de façon que je récupère un
récupère tout je vais regarder tout ça
alors valeurs d'intérêt pour tweets
publiés par ac sur cette chaîne switch
on a tous les jeudis à 20h un stream et
que et que du coup le premier jeudi du
mois il ya le tournoi le tournoi
bitstream le tourabi stream le premier
jeudi du mois fortiori à 20h35 905 ces
paroles il qu'on va voir la différence
avec youtube va faire une bonne
expérience dont julia tout de suite sur
la chaîne youtube comme d'hab vous
mettre un petit lien dans le live mais
on va tout de suite en dessus de
repartir vers youtube aller à 12,8 les
mecs